Je suis parti pour le Nord il y a environ 12 mois
et c'est la première des
découvertes que j'ai faites d'une myriade de mondes
dont le Magistère n'en contrôle qu'un
depuis des siècles ils essaient de
nous garder là où ils nous veulent à genoux
vous avez promis le  Le contrôle du rendement du magistère est
réel, ils devront
prendre l'affaire en main
Lara il y a un grand changement à venir qui
nous menacera tous Je vais
vous donner quelque chose qu'est-ce que c'est - cela a un rôle
à jouer dans tout cela et un  un majeur dites-
moi où est l'Alethea mati nous
représentons un certain nombre de familles qui ont
perdu des enfants c'est la guerre
je pense que les nouvelles peuvent aider
elle peut lire le compteur de Lethe elle
nous sera plus précieuse que n'importe quel soldat
que nous avons récupérera nos enfants  vous avez
peut-être du cœur mais le Magistère a du
muscle de quoi d'autre avons-nous besoin pour
les combattre c'est un bon ours vous n'aurez aucun
problème que les sorcières
connaissent des autres mondes
depuis des milliers d'années
Azrael apporte une grande guerre alors j'espère que
je suis  fort n'a pas vraiment besoin de mourir
maintenant c'est le moment de choisir son camp il y a
des choses telles des choses importantes
pour elle
quel est le monde voit les possibilités
plus d'oppression malheureuse il
n'y a plus d'abus plus d'obscurité le destin de plus
que ce monde dépend d'elle
toi